hey guys this is the just pearly things
youtube channel and today i am going to
be
reviewing a music video by frito
bank top featuring little dirk so i'm a
country music fan
i don't really do a lot of rap music
but i'm going to give like my review of
the music video and the lyrics
and my interpretation of them if you
like this type of content and you want
to see
more don't forget to press the like
subscribe button leave a comment let me
know what you think do you agree with my
interpretation or do you think i'm a
little off
so i'm gonna start the video now
okay there's a lot of people
they look pretty cool they're like hyped
up i've never been to a party like that
but
okay they're going on a plane
okay he's saying he's the type of guy to
work hard he's a hard worker and he
doesn't
just rely on faith he puts in the work
um however there's a lot of fake people
that come around when you're uh one you
just taught me this term earlier a
stepper
step so that's that's my interpretation
um
people looking really cool there's a lot
of people like surrounding them
i got prizes with some [ __ ] because i
won't be fake
[ __ ]
cause i wouldn't talk you heard that
side of the story but that [ __ ] was
false the only ones that want revenge is
the ones they lost
i got [ __ ] mad at me cause i wouldn't
crawl
so first she's saying that like he
is not fake everyone else is fake but
not him
he's special i guess um
and now he's saying that he had a court
case
i i don't know what was going on in the
court case but he's saying
he didn't talk and they only heard the
other side of the story
which is confusing because
like you didn't talk what did you expect
to happen
like of course they're only going to
believe the other side of the story
this just sounds like poor planning on
your part but we're going to continue
okay he's just basically saying that
he's like cooler than everyone
i think so first he goes in like i got a
gun
you don't have a gun therefore i'm the
cool one or i'm
on the real one then he's saying
everyone else is not real
he's real oh and then he's saying he had
to turn his thug up
this is a little confusing for me
honestly because
i thought a thug like when i hear thug
on the news
i think that's the bad guy
but like you want to be more thug
like how do you want to be more thug
that's a little confusing
but okay had to put my love up
cause i don't know who hate no more they
say i'm dead i don't even want to wait
no more
i can't walk my face every day i wake up
to some
it's like it's the same thing we kind of
talked about this earlier but basically
he's saying like
everyone else is fake but not him
and he's a lot cooler than everyone else
i'm still confused why would you want to
turn your thug
up like i thought thug was like the bad
guy
and now you want to be more
air [ __ ]
mama see my cousin down my face i
couldn't help
your clothes homie i'll try to backdoor
you if you love them i just hit the tax
150
it looks like like before his family
couldn't afford stuff
but i think i think they can now
it looks like i'm a little confused
because it says 150 if you catch them
so do you guys not like go to the police
or like
if you get like wouldn't you want to go
to like a detective you're just like
offering up cash
and who got did someone die i think i
missed that part
and when you fall out with your brothers
just don't let them go and ain't telling
before they die i wish i let them know
standing over your body i got my tears
together
i just let you know i got your kids
taking
so it looks like the 150 was for some
like it was maybe his brother
because he's saying here that like you
can't let your brother
or like your friends or whatever can't
not tell them you love them because
like they might die but then he's saying
like he's gonna take care of the kids
and make sure everyone's taken care of
which i think is a very
wholesome quality message like i think
that's great
good messaging
they're all looking really cool in this
honestly
how do you have this many friends
do a lot of people just like party by
planes i mean this kind of goes bad it's
the same thing i said before
like he's saying he's the hard worker
everyone else is like fake like
and he's real
and sometimes people don't like him
because he's real that's that's like i
would say the chorus
in in a summary
why do you want to turn your thug up
it's kind of catchy honestly
these are interesting parties like
the parties i went to in college did not
it had a different vibe i don't know how
to describe it but
it was a little different it was a
little different but overall i thought
it was a cool
music video there was some wholesome
messaging i liked the part
about you know your loved ones before
they're gone whatever um i think if i
was in the car
i would look like pretty cool with this
song on like honestly
i'm gonna give the video like a seven
out of ten
because there were just some parts where
i really didn't understand what they
were saying
if you liked this video and you want to
see more don't forget to like
comment subscribe let me know if you
guys like these videos i'm gonna do more
of them
i think next time i could do like a
country rap song that would be cool